learned the accent as best i could i
read all the biographies princess diana
wasn't called the people's princess for
nothing she resonated with millions of
individuals across the globe so it's
only natural that hollywood would want
to keep her alive on our screens but it
hasn't been without difficulty in fact
some would even call it terrifying many
actresses have tried to take on her
character even a royal relative and
while some have been true contenders
others have fallen just under the royal
requirements
when i look at her i feel like i don't
know what's going to happen who would
have thought that kristen stewart would
be going from playing bella swan to
princess diana within a few years being
very young when she passed kristen
didn't fully grasp who diana was until
she dove deep into her history i've not
been as consumed by something in so long
and soon became protective over her and
her story kristin had a very unique way
of preparing for the role it was just
about allowing her to affect me but as
she said she soon realized that there
was no proper or perfect way to play her
the biographies and videos she watched
would never be enough nevertheless
kristin admits that the most
intimidating part of it all was her
voice the accent is intimidating as hell
because people know that voice and it's
so distinct to help with the accent she
worked with dialogue coach william who
helped her realize that the key to it
all was to not rely on mimicking diana
but on creating the illusion of a
character i learned the accent as best i
could as for the physical transformation
kristen described diana's hair as
architectural which meant to achieve the
perfect look they had to build upon
kristen's real dyed hair the perfect
hair mixed with near-perfect wardrobe
replicas supported kristin's performance
amazingly i'm genuinely so excited to
see you take on the role of princess
diana elizabeth debicki is the lucky
actress who was chosen to take on the
role of princess diana in the final
season of the crown and like a lot of
people she was in awe of what this woman
actually brought to the world yeah she
exists in a profound way so it was only
natural for her to dive into the world
of dukes and duchesses right away but it
wasn't without some trepidation i'm
terrified and i'm excited with her
blonde hair and glowing personality
elizabeth had the advantage of already
resembling diana but she had to do some
major research in order to fully
understand her as a person in order to
really embody her elizabeth even used
the feelings of loneliness that came out
of the kovid 19 pandemic and lockdown
the difference between being entirely on
your own or being able to see a friend
and go for a walk down the street that
makes you regain perspective princess
diana had an eventful life that
elizabeth seemed to truly grasp
emma corrin wasn't even two when the
world lost diana and according to the
actress that really affected how she
took on the role of the young princess
in season four of the crown so in order
to get to know her emma interviewed
people who had been in her life like
diana's private secretary patrick
jefferson although she got some vital
information from patrick like how diana
had a natural inclination towards
happiness she called speaking to people
who knew her a bittersweet experience
nevertheless she dove into studying
history and working with her movement
and vocal coach paulie bennett she even
nailed diana's dialect for her voice
um it's mainly that everything goes
sort of goes down at the end and would
constantly repeat all right
all right to get into character as for
her physical transformation makeup
designer kate hall designed six
different wigs to replicate really
historic diana's moments and even used
photos for makeup reference but the real
showstopper was the wardrobe
specifically the replica of diana's
wedding dress that had the entire
production in awe and i just remember
this harsh descending
over everyone the crown had help from
diana's wedding dress designers david
and elizabeth emanuel to make this
moment as realistic as possible overall
emma says during the process she got to
know diana like you would a friend
doctor
this is diana preparing for her role as
diana in the movie diana was no joke for
naomi watts before even starting
production she was put through a
three-month workout and diet regime in
order to get her frame as similar to
diana's as possible as for the emotional
part of it all naomi realized how
tedious it was to play someone like
diana i mean it's it's delicate however
she did all the research she could on
diana before diving into the role i read
all the biographies um i looked at every
piece of footage but she wanted to make
sure she didn't fall into trying to
mimic her she prepared so much there
were times she would even dream of diana
on set naomi spent hours in the makeup
chair having a prosthetic nose and
multiple wigs applied for the wardrobe
they were able to work with designer
jaka zoguri who created many of diana's
iconic pieces i created replicas of
dresses i had designed for princess
diana with an actress and team as good
as this one it's no wonder naomi was
able to give the world a very accurate
representation of the late princess this
is my princess diane
right from the start bonnie soper was
dedicated to making sure she did diana
justice the casting agents were shocked
when her audition included hair makeup
and costume inspired by the princess
however just their similarity and
appearance alone may have done the trick
her audition tape is just uncanny i like
to be a queen of people's hearts in
people's hearts bonnie says she did the
research for the role and was surprised
at how much her own instincts helped i
get sort of instinctive about some
things and i felt really positive about
this
although the productions she was a part
of weren't as widespread as some of the
other actresses her dedication to the
role did the princess justice it was no
secret that genevieve o'reilly wasn't
the most similar in appearance to
princess diana however she was able to
make up for it with her impeccable
preparation she trained herself with
voice and body language classes in order
to portray her near perfectly genevieve
doesn't look like diana but she can act
i'd think i was watching archive footage
of diana herself
genevieve was also given advice from an
unsuspected person while filming
genevieve was approached by a former
royal servant who told her keep your
chin down and your left eye slightly up
if you want to capture what she really
looked like sometimes it isn't hollywood
professionals who can give you the best
advice but those with real experience
you have to tell your story
i've had to sell mine julie cox fell
into playing diana in a whirlwind she
was cast just a few days before the
filming of princess in love began and
had never read a book or watched a
program about diana while there was the
obvious struggle of her having no
background history on the princess i
thought if i had read it i'll have a
hard time taking the script seriously
transforming her physically was also a
challenge not only did she have brown
hair which they did die but julie is
only five foot four inches in height
that's a whole six inches shorter than
diana was the environment on set was a
very difficult one for julie and the
crew who often complained about unfit
working conditions however in the end
they were able to pull it together and
get the film released
these are for you lovely thank you
serena scott thomas earned the title of
being one of the most identical diana's
that television had ever seen in diana
her true story with a wig and a costume
department that were able to match some
of diana's wardrobe pieces perfectly her
transformation was seamless some
reviewers even admitted to forgetting
they were watching an actress and not
diana herself
catherine oxenburg's portrayal of diana
in the royal romance of charles and
diana was very meta she's third cousins
with prince william and prince harry and
actually attended the ball the day
before diana's wedding something she
thinks makes her even more qualified for
the role at the ball right before their
wedding charles came up to me and he
said would you like to meet diana her
parents had been worried about how their
family would react to the film but
catherine felt she could do the princess
justice to prepare she says she took
many visits to buckingham palace
caroline bliss was one of the original
actors to ever tackle playing diana she
had the advantage of diana still being
alive and being present when the world
fell in love with diana experiencing it
firsthand do you think you'll ever be
queen
no i don't diana led a life of love
compassion and leadership that the world
will never forget while no actress may
ever come close to playing her perfectly
keeping her on the big screen in any
form is a gift to the world which
actress do you think portrayed diana the
best
[Music]